vote artificial intelligence is rapidly
changing our lives which is why EU
lawmakers say regulation is essential
voting in strasbour MEP is approved an
AI bill that once ratified by member
states could become a landmark law by
2025. and it is adopted congratulations
took how many hours days and nights it
will still take for your hard work and
for having found a balanced and
human-centered approach to the world's
first AI act legislation that will no
doubt be setting the global standard for
years to come MEP say AI can be a force
for good in everything from fighting
climate change to education if the
systems are safe and ethical under the
proposed law they'd be categorized
according to risk the higher the risk
the more rules but systems deem to pose
unacceptable risks or curtail freedoms
will be banned including facial
recognition in real time in public
places companies breaking the rules
could be investigated and face penalties
the mighty situations where there will
be infringements that companies would
not be either providing the necessary
information or they would simply with
the applications infringing the rules
under the text and that's when penalties
could apply and they range from taking
the product off the market prohibiting
certain applications from the market all
the way to fines that can go to two to
seven percent of the revenue of the
respective company because because AI is
developing so fast
policy makers to try to try and find the
balance between protecting people's
rights But continuing to Support Tech
innovation
too much regulation in the EU says this
Tech entrepreneur and French government
advisor could lead to an AI brain drain
the risk of regulating too much is to
see all the key players moving to the
U.S for instance and it's a big risk I
can tell you that I've spoken to a few
teams the most advanced in France and
they're really considering that if the
law is too strong that they would move
out of Europe
taken years for EU lawmakers to produce
the AI bill but with technology
advancing so quickly no one can really
predict if it'll still be relevant by
the time it's expected to come into
Force Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
strasbour